what's up people
um i just why is this thing blurry huh
you might have a little frosting or
something on there um
so i decided i'm gonna read through some
of the um
uh commentary on the youtubes
um and i just wanted to read through
some
i just cracked into an episode randomly
and that is episode
40. king and the stings episode 40 baby
um so we're just going to roll through i
know that people
you know rip on me and brennan so i just
wanted to see what people say
um
let me see
oh somebody wrote this guy yeah so i'm
just having a hard time
dealing with my with my girlfriend
leaving me any advice
three minutes later theo so what's this
guy
want clown my hound yeah
and that's by anime sins anime sins man
that is
uh man that got me laughing right there
because yes
it's hard to pay attention you know
there's too much visuality in the room
too much
audio audio you know people talk and
people
you know being alive in front of you
it's hard when everybody's alive in
front of you to pay attention man
um what else we got what else we got
uh theo looks like a nurse at a
children's hospital that's pretty true
that
episode brendan looks like the type of
guy
who can sit on a popsicle blindfolded
and tell which flavor it is damn
man man alive lordy lord
and that's st stevo khan or steve ocon
[Laughter]
wow um
let me see i used to like it when it was
just theo and brendan talking [ __ ] and
improvising then
sometimes chin will come into the
conversation now it's a full blown show
with five people
yeah it gets a little tricky sometimes
man
sometimes i want to make it more where
we just get to rip on each other
so um
theo looks like the kid from home alone
if his parents never
came back
[Laughter]
that's hilarious dude brendan looks like
a native american that disguised himself
as a white guy in a rush
man y'all killing me here dude brennan
and first of all will brendan decide how
to spell his name
bro i've seen him write his name down
five or six times he spells it
differently almost every time
like he's just guessing
brendan looks like a native american
that disguised himself as a white guy
in a rush then helped kim
kill his people
man and that's by maxwell morton right
there
maximo getting it done um
let me see
man everybody ripped on chappelle in
this episode man
uh
brendan looks like the drummer for
syndrome of a downs
that's crazy man and that's a crazy
disease
man two
uh
let me see
oh
dang everybody on here just hating on
chappelle man
sorry just funny man how people you know
go through different
phases uh
you look like an assistant manager at an
ant farm
somebody wrote and i don't know
i don't know if we said that i don't
know if we said that
in the episode or not but daniel hey
that was good
uh let me see
theo looks like a combination of every
lunch lady in the world who also runs a
petting
zoo but it's only full of but it's only
full of raccoons
[Laughter]
brendan looks like and that's bernardo
wilbur
brendan looks like he decided to chase
his dream of being a dj
at age 40.
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
theo looks like ellen degeneres if she
was transgender
which she might be i mean do we even
know she's got so much money she could
have a
you know everything detachable uh and
those comments the original one was od
dog 22
and that one was uh benjamin hember
so yeah i just wanted to read through a
couple comments and um
and acknowledge that so
that's acknowledged right there and uh
thank you guys for checking out the uh
the program
you know yeah